I grew up a dancer I walked into that
dance studio and I think even at 3 I
knew it would be my life's passion when
I started teaching I didn't know there
was a void in the fitness industry I was
doing my passion I love to dance I love
to share it with other people
never knowing that it would evolve into
what it is today but I'm sure as heck
glad it did Jazzercise has many
definitions it's a dance fitness class
that couples cardiovascular training but
also strength training and muscle work
as well in 1969 I was teaching a very
strict jazz dance class there are a lot
of women in my classes and they would
come and go they didn't stay and that
bugged me that's what gave me the idea
to do what I did to make it fun and
simple and that caught on and then it
just grew Jazzercise has become a huge
community all around the world we have
today about 8,500 franchisees globally
it just got bigger and bigger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I first started teaching there
wasn't really an option for women it was
so male-dominated you gotta put your
feet okay now turn to somebody and say
good morning okay so I don't think women
really thought about coming to class as
it being a fitness class it was
something that was fun they made friends
they sweat and then they saw their
bodies change how we do but it goes
beyond that there's a real community to
our classes step back
Jazzercise just brings everything to
life it makes me physically well it
makes me mentally well and besides I get
to meet my friends and see all my
friends I feel like this community or
the family I like to you family instead
let me get some family here like we come
we support each other I can't do without
you you know that don't you
I just always wanted people to come in
the door and feel good about themselves
and feel like they were home yes you
just start with abduction okay so no
introduction just starts right off the
bat yes okay when I come up with new
routines there's really a lot of
different things that are mixed together
to make that happen I will select songs
my daughter Shanna who's president of
the company will select songs and we'll
work together touch we videotape all
that material and then it gets streamed
to our franchisees everywhere all over
the world how about let's do life is a
dance floor okay sounds good okay now
give me three lunges one two it takes us
about ten weeks we do 30 to 35 different
routines so it's something new every ten
weeks and push push three lunges one two
I love teaching I love doing
choreography those two things are my
favorite part of what I do it keeps me
going forward I feel really lucky
because Jazzercise has really enabled me
to experience so many different kinds of
situations
I've been able to run the Olympic torch
we've been able to do the opening
ceremonies for the 1984 Olympics to
dance in those we've done numerous NFL
half times MB a half times we have been
able to do different kinds of
presentations throughout the world
I had no blueprint I have no master plan
I am more than blessed to be a part of
this community we're celebrating our
fiftieth anniversary this year and
people always say to me are you still
teaching when they aren't you who don't
you want to retired you know I'm gonna
do this as long as I can walk
[Music]